I'd still be playing this game even if I
wasn't being paid for it not that not
that I don't want to be paid for it I
don't think I would change anything
because I think it's important to go
through life with without any regrets I
just want people to see me as a as a
hard-working footballer someone that's
passionate about the game it was
probably the toughest moment in my
career
[Music]
having difference I never felt safe for
three and a half years he's an English
former professional football player in
2004 he was named to the FIFA 100 list
of the greatest living players he is
consistently ranked among the highest
earners in football he's David Beckham
and here is my take on his top 10 rules
for Success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'm curious if
your girl which one you guys like the
best and as always if David says
something that really really resonates
with you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
thank you
I've always been driven you know even at
a young age all I ever wanted to do was
become a footballer a soccer star and
that was my only ambition you know I
know it's different these days with kids
you know there's obviously there's Fame
there's fortune and it might be easy for
me to say that because obviously I've
done I've done very well out of the game
but you know I'd still be playing this
game even if I wasn't being paid for it
not that not that I don't want to be
paid for it but
but I um I still would be playing
playing playing this this sport
[Music]
when I sit with kids and they turn
around and say you know how can we be
professional footballers the one thing I
always say to them is a you have to
enjoy yourself you have to have fun
playing football if you want to be a
professional footballer then you have to
have fun but more importantly you have
to be dedicated you have to make
sacrifices and I think sacrifices was
probably one of the most important
things for me because you know I was as
a young kid living in London friends you
know going out on a Friday night but I
made a sacrifice of staying in watching
much of the day on a Saturday evening
and I had a game on the Sunday so I was
in bed early and you know those those
kind of things you know for young kids
are important
[Music]
thank you
I don't think I would change anything
because I think it's important to go
through life with without any regrets
people have said to me would you change
98 would you change the red card against
Argentina do I wish it hadn't have
happened of course
but if it hadn't have happened would I
have been the player that I am today
would have been a strong person on the
field and off the field that I am today
so
there's nothing nothing I regret
[Music]
people have asked me that over the years
you know how do I curl a ball how do I
bend the ball and yeah it's something
that just happened it's not something
that
um I thought okay I want to bend the
ball better than anyone else so I'm
going to kick the ball in this certain
way
um I just worked on my striking of the
ball I just practiced every day it's
something that I've done from a very
young age you know even after every
training session you know I take balls
on on my own and and just curl and kick
and and and try and find new ways of of
getting the ball in the net without
anyone touching it and uh you know I've
been lucky enough to have done that over
the years with uh with the wire kick the
ball and I know that it's a unique style
and I know I know it's a unique Style
Just because my back hurts a little bit
more than than it did when I was 15
years old but
um no you know it's something that I
practice of course you know it's one
thing I tell kids and unless you
practice you're never gonna
um you know get better at something
[Music]
people measure success with
obviously my field by Trophies by medals
by the success that I have had over my
career personally I measure success on
have I had a good time have I had fun
have I reached the goals that I wanted
to reach when I was eight or nine years
old I wanted to Captain my country I
wanted to represent my country in a
world cup I wanted to win the FA Cup you
know and and luckily I achieved all
those streams
thank you
how do you want to be remembered
as a football player as a person over
these last 22 years and everything that
you've achieved as someone who did what
achieved what was most important to you
I just want people to see me as a as a
hard-working footballer someone that's
passionate about the game and someone
that every time I stepped on the pitch
um I've given everything that I have
um because that's a that's how I feel
going into games at the end of my career
that's how I look back on it and hope
people will see me
um because I think over the years it's
been
you know my my life and my my career
people have obviously looked at certain
other things that have gone on
throughout my career and I think
sometimes that's overshadowed what I've
done on the pitch or what I've achieved
on the pitch
um and that's as much as I say that that
doesn't hurt me of course it does you
know I'm I'm at the end of the day I'm a
footballer that has played for some of
the biggest clubs in the world played
with some of the best players in the
world played for under the some of the
the biggest and best managers and and
achieved almost everything in football
and I think
of course it hurts when people not
question it but think about other things
and
to come to the end of my career now and
look back and say you know I've I've
achieved everything with every club that
I've played for played for my country
115 times
been runner up twice uh well play of the
year to
two amazing footballers
um
I'm very proud of that
how do you keep the balance between work
and family obviously you've got a hectic
life around the world what's that like I
mean obviously as a family we're very
busy as a couple we're very busy
Victoria's got a collection that he's
obviously doing unbelievably well but
there's a lot of pressure that comes
with that obviously
um you know and I'm working every day I
play and train every day so it's it's
difficult but like I said before you
know our number one priority is our
children and their family nothing else
gets in the way of that you know when
I'm away Victoria's at home with the
boys and and Harper when when she's away
vice versa so you know we're uh we're
very Hands-On parents you know I I take
the kids to school every day pick them
up every day we go Taekwondo we go
soccer we go you know there's so many
things that we do with the kids and like
I said we're very Hands-On parents so
you know it doesn't our lives our busy
lives don't affect you know the children
in any way but but the children
understand that we work very hard as
well so
um you know we've got we've got a very
good balance there
I just feel that
I've been so lucky throughout my career
I just feel that you know the fact that
I've played for the clubs that I've
played for the players I've played with
won the
trophies that I've won
um
you know playing in the MLS last year uh
winning the championship there and then
coming to PSG and winning the French
league here
um
I think it's you know it's a good way to
go out you've always gone out on a hire
every Club at United winning a league
Madrid MLS LA Galaxy last year is that
is that important to you what's happened
in the last few weeks with PSG that you
you've gone out as a winner
um I think it's it's every athlete's
dream every footballer's dream to go out
on the top uh you know on top form or
winning a trophy you know it doesn't
happen uh that often but you know I've
been lucky obviously when I left United
uh we won the league when I left
um when I left Madrid we won the league
uh like you said leaving the Galaxy you
know doing uh two years of winning the
championship there and then obviously
coming here and winning the league
um it's nice to it's nice to go out like
that you know I think people look back
and you know it's it's written you know
it's simple you're leaving as a champion
and I think that's why I think there's
the right time
[Music]
do you ever visualize you winning or
anything in your head you know always
trying to win in the world cup but that
happened yet
[Music]
[Applause]
still look back to 98.
after the red card that I got against
Argentina what went on in my life and in
my family's life after that I think was
very tough it was probably the toughest
moment in my career
[Music]
I was having death threats I never felt
safe for three and a half years
people used to turn around and they're
saying that you've let your country down
and you've let your family down so how
does that feel I don't think I'd ever
felt as alone as that as a person as a
footballer it can knock a person down so
much that they just go under
outside pubs in London there was
Effigies hung of me and this was on the
front of the newspaper
it's just something that sticks in my
mind from that time
one thing I've said about me at the time
there was a headline of 10 lines one
stupid little boy
still emotional isn't it still raw here
a saying that I use all the time and
it's it's true he's around world
98 was just before the World Cup where I
was at the top then
after I woke up I was at the bottom and
then you work yourself back up the
upside for me was the grease game
once the game started was the start of
an incredible day for me
obviously we're going to the World Cup
that day or it was going into qualifying
games which none of us wanted to do
because the expectations of us I
remember Teddy shearing getting a free
kick on the edge of the box and I
remember putting the ball down and I
remember looking up at the clock and
thinking this is it you know this is the
only chance I'm gonna get now yeah
he owns the man and his rum around about
here I think and then I stepped back
took the deep breaths run up and as soon
as it left my foot I knew it was in
it was the loudest I think I've ever
heard the fans it was such a huge moment
for everyone I remember just running off
and being that excited just jumping up
in the air you know I could have touched
the top of the stadium if I wanted to
because I felt that higher
right the whole canvas is the idea of
the gold there's the ball in the corner
my celebration and the words belief
strength of family is what I needed and
what I had to get through after 98.
being in front of a blank piece of paper
with experts around you as well I think
that is much more daunting than stepping
out in front of 90 000 people playing
football
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because pag labai asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did you learn from David
today what was the most inspiring thing
or most interesting thing that you
pulled from this video leave it in the
comments below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to John D Webster John
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book and tweeting it I really
really appreciate it so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon foreign